we're in New York we went out to dinner  I said I can't stay out too late because  my boss is expecting me to deliver a  song by the end of the day tomorrow and  I just found that fascinating because to  me if there's any artist in the world  who doesn't have a boss it's I think  this says more equal amount about you  that it does about me that you are  fixated on my having a boss if you ever  want to write a musical um I would not  possibly presume to improve on this  incredible team we could call your boss  Tommy is Tommy his name tough Tommy  Tommy Tommy wouldn't even know what it  was long  give us lin-manuel  yeah I cannot tell you how mad he got  when I said you don't have a boss yeah  yeah there's no one in the I was  frustrated you wrote Hamilton why are  you writing people you don't have a boss  man and then some guy named Tommy was  like is that right  lin-manuel doesn't have a boss let me  tell you about his father's death